so the reason I wrote this book is I
think there's a lot of confusion out
there about how you supposed to manage
your life in your career the challenge
is not how to become a success or meet
others definition of success the
challenge is how to reach your own
unique potential being successful often
means meeting someone else's definition
of success usually involves metrics
achieving certain status prominence fame
whatever they're all external
manifestations reaching your potential
is a much more fulfilling path may not
meet others definition of success it
means creating your own definition of
success and then trying to develop
yourself so you're doing things that fit
your skills fit your passions and help
you make the most of your talents
you